[Music]
okay none of you are my child has anyone
seen miriah
we are fighting a war 30 years in the
future
the joke our enemy is not human
we need you to fight you got drafted
i will be back why is this happening
what about the teachers deferment
and the veterans deferment if i don't go
they're going to draft you in my place
but if something does happen to me you
and me will be taken care of
if something happens to you dan 70
of draftees do not return sometimes a
man does what's best for his family
not himself move your shirt please
what's this for
it's just a test oh a seat belt was it a
driving test
no you don't have jokes in the future
this device facilitates your jump to and
from the future war
one minute to jump i'll hear everybody
take that
you just look around like that are you
so calm long story yeah
it's military yeah kind of a short story
i guess
three two one
in 11 months time all human beings in
the future will be wiped from the face
of the earth
unless you help us
i was trying to save my daughter if i
got to save the world to save her then
i'm gonna do it
this is the end the human species will
disappear from the face of the earth
we are literally living on borrow time
there's still a chance that we can stop
this war from ever happening
so we gotta fight
well it's nice knowing you
[Music]
[Music]
you